We ended last time by talking about the sense in which champagnes page has
competitive democracy is minimalist.
And I said that it is an important sense minimalist.
It's linked to this idea of the competitive struggle for power and the eye.
The notion that,
um,
turfing the rascals out is,
is um,
the sing quando on of democratic politics.
Um,
there's one respect in which even if this is a middle minimal requirement,
it's nonetheless a very substantial minimal requirement.
So the,
the basic issue wise,
um,
is this conception of democracy to minimalist.
Um,
it is minimalist in,
in an important sense in that it reduces democracy to this competitive struggle
for the people's vote.
I said it's this one restrict in which is clearly is not minimalist,
which is that if,
if one's expectation is as Huntington and others would come to argue later that
we can call a democracy,
a country,
a democracy,
until there've been two turnovers of overs of power.
That means the U S was not a democracy until 1840.
Um,
Japan has only recently become a democracy.
Countries like South Africa and not yet democracies or we can at least we can't
say they are a,
because we don't know what would happen if the ANC lost an election.
So minimalist,
not negligible.
And I think that,
uh,
for those who complain that Shit Schumpeterian democracy is to minimalist shoe.
I living in a country that doesn't have it.
Uh,
and you will find that,
uh,
that,
that minimal is indeed not negligible.
Still you might say that raises the question of what it is that we can
reasonably expect from democracy because most people typically expect more from
democracy then just the turnover of government.
And if we,
if we go back to the large themes of this course,
um,
remember that when I introduced the subject of democracy and we looked at Plato
and Tocqueville's critiques of it,
um,
we,
we really were left wondering,
well,
why,
why would anyone think that if,
if protecting individual rights and basing politics on scientific principles of
truth is the,
is the answer,
why would we want it?
Why would we want to,
uh,
pursue democracy as the goal to achieving that answer?
Um,
but if you now take a step back and ask,
well,
compared to what democracy starts look pretty good because what we have seen in
the literature on democracy is that,
um,
no other political system does a better job of protecting individual rights.
We saw that Madison was greatly concerned with the separation of power and the
creation of,
we might call Republican constraints on democracy,
but the literature from the 20th century has established principally by Bob
Doll,
but also from many others that if you look at,
if,
if you look at the addition of con judicial review is just not something that
lawyers like to hear.
But if you look at the addition of judicial review to democratic politics,
it doesn't really add anything.
That is to say the way in which empirically rights are best protected is by
creating Schumpeterian democracy.
Adding judicial review on top of that doesn't seem to make any difference as far
as preserving individual rights is concerned.
Uh,
the big thing is to get and keep democracy not to get and keep judicial review.
And a,
I think that is reflected in the fact that a separation of powers at the end of
the day,
his words upon a parchment,
where's the,
the pluralism that guarantees competitive politics is embedded in the society.
And that is ultimately the guarantor of freedom under democratic conditions.
If we think about the truth coming out in politics basing Po,
finding a political system that as male would have,
it could bash track the truth.
Um,
again,
what we've,
what we find when we ask the question compared to what democracy does better
than the going alternatives.
Uh,
you can think of Schumpeterian competition as institutionalizing mills demand
that,
um,
we have to have competition of ideas.
Remember how Mel got from freedom to a utility through his idea of the truth
coming out of competitive argument,
not deliberation,
not sitting around and contemplating things together,
but people having to argue for their views and defend them,
uh,
on the grounds that a,
they can meet the objections of their,
uh,
critics.
And so Schumpeterian ism is a kind of institutionalization of the,
the competitive argumentative ideal.
Uh,
that mill talks about in the long chapter on freedom of speech in on liberty.
And so again,
when we say compared to what,
um,
democracy does better than the going alternatives in preserving the freedom of
speech and the competition of ideas that is likely to make the truth come out in
the long run.
Uh,
so despite the fears of Plato and Tocqueville,
when we pose the question compared to what democracy does better than the going
alternatives in vindicating these enlightenment ideals,
as Churchill said,
democracy is the worst system of government except for the others that have been
tried from time to time.
Now you could,
you could,
uh,
by everything I've just said now,
but still feel that this is too minimalistic conception of democracy to meet the
sort of expectations that people have when they make demands for the creation of
democracy in the real world.
And I think there's merit to that objection.
And these last two lectures are designed to address it to the extent that I
think it's possible to address it.
If we think about the condition on conditions under which people demand
democracy,
they usually conditions under which people have a strong experience of
injustice.
So those of us who were around in the 1980s would hear objections from behind
the iron curtain to communism.
People didn't like communism and what they demanded was democracy.
Or if you go to apartheid South Africa,
what you find is,
um,
again,
people find,
find themselves appalled by and rejecting of apartheid.
But what do they demand?
They demand democracy.
Now,
if in either of those interests instances,
you went to those people who would dim,
who does anticommunist,
who were demanding democracy in the former Soviet Union,
or the anti apartheid activists who were demanding democracy in South Africa.
Um,
and you said to them,
well,
tell us what a perfect democracy would look like in Russia or in South Africa.
They wouldn't have been able to tell you.
And I think that that's an important observation.
It's an important observation because it captures a feature of human nature that
we haven't commented on very much.
Um,
although it came to the surface in our discussion of Mcintyre,
namely,
that human beings are reactive creatures.
They shy away from what does not work.
Uh,
and then fumble in the darkness in search of something that works better or at
least something that fails less badly.
Okay.
The famous economist and Marty Sen,
uh,
how I mentioned to you briefly,
I think made this point brilliantly in a new book of his called the idea of
justice and express some of his frustration with the academic literature on
justice,
which seems to get caught up in debating questions that are three points to the
right of the decimal,
uh,
without moving on the big questions of justice.
And send said,
imagine,
imagine that you were sitting in a sauna,
a and the controls for the sauna were outside so you couldn't reach them.
Um,
and it got hotter and hotter and hotter and you were really,
really hot.
And you said to the person,
uh,
who had their hand on the controls outside this one,
turn it down.
It's way too hot.
And his reply was,
well,
I'm not going to turn it down and tell you,
tell me what the optimal tangent temperature is.
And of course,
what sends point is you don't know what the optimal tenture temperature is.
What you know is this is much too hot.
Um,
and so I think sends,
sends a little story in a more imaginative way then than anything I have come up
with,
captures this idea that human beings are reactive creatures and we,
we,
we say,
this doesn't work.
This doesn't work.
And we constantly looking for something that does better.
And so the fact that anticommunist in the 1980s couldn't describe what a well
functioning a post Soviet democracy would look like,
or the fact that,
uh,
anti apartheid activists in the 1970s and eighties couldn't characterize a
democratic South Africa for you in any detail,
doesn't detract from the fact that their demands for democracy captured,
uh,
something about what they thought was fundamentally unacceptable about the
existing state of affairs.
And so,
um,
people demand democracy because they experience injustice and they want justice
and they hope that democracy will deliver it.
Yeah.
Now some shown per Tarion's Huntington,
a foremost among them have said,
this is really bad.
This is really a bad thing because what's going to happen when people experience
injustice and demand democracy is there inevitably they are inevitably going to
be disappointed.
Indeed.
There was a very interesting poll I thought,
uh,
out of South Africa on this very point last year where they found a majority of
South African blacks saying things were better under apartheid then now,
but then when asked would they rather go back to apartheid?
And majority said no,
uh,
captures,
I think this tension in this paradoxical,
a expectation that people have of democracy,
but the hunting Tony and point was well,
uh,
that you wouldn't,
you would jeopardize democracy if you get people to load too many expectations
onto it.
The,
this to some extent is defined in the second half of that pole.
I just meant to,
I just mentioned to you because even though people say things were better in,
in the apartheid is they still don't want to go back there.
Um,
but,
but I think Huntington might say,
well,
eventually things are going to change.
Eventually when South African democracy fails to deliver on people's
expectations about justice,
the regime itself is going to become into jeopardy.
If you look at South Africa,
just to pursue this example,
we've now had four elections since apartheid.
Uh,
South Africa's one of the most unequal countries in the world has one of the
highest Jenny coefficients.
Yet the top marginal tax rate today is lower than it was at the end of
apartheid.
There hasn't been land reform.
There hasn't been significant redistribution of income or wealth because a being
the creation of a small black millionaire class,
but for the vast majority of blacks there are still as badly off as they were
before.
And so the hunting Tonia and thought is that if people load expectations onto
democracy that can't be met,
then when those demar expectations are frustrated,
eventually the,
the,
the problem is going to be that people are going to blame democracy rather than
the government of the day and turn on democracy when some,
a populous dictated comes along and promises,
say as we've seen in Zimbabwe,
a promises massive land redistribution,
uh,
at the expense of democracy.
And so the modern Shump Ontarians have tended to say we should try and disabuse
people of their unrealistic expectations of democracy,
um,
so that we don't lose at least the minimal benefits of competitive democracy,
which we've already agreed on,
not negligible.
And so that this was presented as a kind of realist,
a real politic take on a democracy that people shouldn't expect it to do to
diminish injustice.
The problem with the Hunting Tony and view is that people are not going to
change their expectations because some professor of political science tells them
to,
there are deep seated reasons why people turn to democracy when they experience
injustice and,
uh,
and not going to give up on the appeal to democracy in order to remedy yet.
Um,
and those reasons have to do with,
I think with the,
the topic we ended at,
at the very tail end of,
of,
uh,
last Wednesday's lecture is that democracy is motivated.
The impulse for democracy is,
comes from the impulse to resist domination.
And there's a connection between democracy and fighting injustice because both
of those things are connected with resistance to domination.
So if we think that the,
um,
shown per Tarion's up our right to say that democracy is often going to fail to
deliver on the project of diminishing injustice,
but naive to think that people are therefore going to stop,
uh,
creating expectations of democracy,
that creates a different kind of agenda that creates the agenda that I want to
talk to you about for the rest of today's lecture and,
uh,
Wednesday's lecture.
And that is how can we think about promoting justice by democratic means,
given that people are going to have expectations from democracy,
the better course is to try and find institutions that can deliver on those
expectations.
And I think it's an important reason,
not only when we reasoned about democracy,
but also when we reason about justice.
Uh,
many years ago when I was teaching this course,
uh,
before I had written democratic justice and indeed one of the,
the events that caused me to ride it was a question from a student in the class.
Um,
I had gone,
I had been teaching roles and I had gone through the principles,
the difference principle and all of that.
And,
and I had explained that rolls was the most influential political philosopher of
his generation and that this theory of justice had completely revolution,
arised a modern political philosophy.
And the student put up their hand and said,
Professor Shapiro,
now that rolls has theory has been established.
Why hasn't the constitution being changed to include it?
And many of the students in the class laughed and they laughed.
Why?
Why does have a guess?
Why do you think people laughed?
Okay.
It seemed like a naive question.
Why though?
Why,
you know,
he said,
look,
you got the ride and John Ross got the answer.
So our Constitution doesn't reflect that answer.
Why haven't they changed it?
Why do you think students would have laughed?
Yeah,
people think there's a disconnect sometimes between political philosophy in
actual politics.
Awesome.
They think there's a disconnect between political philosophy and actual
politics.
But why,
why is there a disconnect?
Um,
I mean,
these political philosophers are trying to get the right answer.
So let's suppose it's true that role's got the right answer.
And Nozick did intend to walk in,
didn't and,
and Shapiro data didn't,
you know,
roles got the right answer.
He solved the problem.
Why don't we just implemented this was after all what Bentham thought,
you know,
when Bentham,
Ben Fam thought he'd figured it all out and he went running around the world
with his constitutions and was deeply disappointed when current countries
wouldn't adopt them.
Why do we resist this idea?
Yeah.
At the back.
Can we get the microphone to the back?
Okay.
Because generally we don't think that claims are absolutely true and we
maintained that they can be,
um,
proved false in the future.
Like claims are fallible.
Okay.
So part of it is the Falabella some of the mature enlightenment that people,
people somehow resist the idea that anybody's got it perfectly right in the
sense of getting a geometric proof.
Anything else?
Yeah.
Over here.
Just,
just hold us.
Okay.
We want to record what you say for posterity.
Democratic system doesn't change that fast.
I mean,
part of the nature of the system that we have is that it's slow moving and,
uh,
it's slow moving.
Yeah.
But still,
why shouldn't it move?
You know,
they had these,
the student might say,
uh,
well,
yeah,
okay.
But you know,
so they had these ideas in the 18th century.
Now Rawls has better ideas.
Why should we move to Ross has ideas.
I think there's some thing that will make people resist.
There are many people who might concede that Rawls has a better argument than
nosy d'ivoire.
Dworkin was Shapiro.
Why will any of the other people mail that you've been reading and still want to
say it shouldn't be imposed on the society that somehow principles of justice
have to be democratically legitimated in order for us to be forced to live by
them.
And so I think whether you start from the justice and uh,
we and your f you confronted by this reality that people demand democracy when
they experience injustice or when you start from the democracy end,
you realize that,
um,
people,
ugh,
not going to embrace principles of justice unless they can try them through
democratic institutions.
Um,
you realize that pursuing democracy and justice together is important.
After all,
as I said to you when I talked to you about Madison,
even though they thought they had designed the best constitution that they could
agree to at the time,
uh,
nobody had any illusions that,
that this would be acceptable if it had not been adopted by the people of the
state of New York.
Um,
so having the right answer is not enough.
You've got to have the right answer,
but convince people through democratic mechanisms that you've got the right
answer.
So democracy and justice have to be pursued together.
I said that the animating idea behind,
um,
democracy is the,
the appeal of resisting domination.
But I think it,
the,
the procedural,
um,
ground rule is what I'm going to call the principle of affected interests.
And,
and this was no where better articulated than by Nelson Mandela in 1962 in his,
um,
statement to the court before sentencing.
Uh,
some,
a little piece of relevant background that you may not know.
You have to write this down.
I will put it up.
I'll put it up on the,
uh,
server,
piece of background is that they had been convicted of treason.
Um,
the ANC had finally suspended,
uh,
had,
had finally suspended.
They're peaceful,
uh,
opposition about five years earlier and turn to armed struggle.
And then a number of ANC leaders had been arrested and tried and convicted of
treason and their attorneys,
uh,
told them that they were going to get the death sentence and the only way they
could possibly avoid the death sentence was to get up and be contrite and beg to
be led off.
And,
and the young Nelson Mandela said,
no,
I'm not going to do that.
And he stood up and he made this famous speech in which he said,
I'm,
I'm charged with inciting people to commit an offense by way of protest against
the law.
A law for which neither I or any of my people had any say in preparing.
But in weighing up the decision as to the sentence which should be imposed for
such an offense,
the court must take into account the question of responsibility.
Whether it is I who is responsible or whether in fact a large measure of the
responsibility does not lie on the shoulders of the government,
which promulgated that law.
Knowing that my people who constitute the majority of the population of this
country,
we're opposed to that law.
And knowing further that every legal means of demonstrating that opposition had
been closed to them by prior legislation and government administrative action.
We played no role in making the laws that affect us and we have no means of
opposing the laws that affect us is what he was saying.
And that's why we turned to the arms struggle and it's not our,
uh,
our failing.
They of course,
uh,
the government was calling them terrorists of course.
Uh,
why,
what did they call them?
Terrorists.
But man,
Dallas position was that the principle of affected anxious had been violated.
This notion that I think is very close to the most fundamental prince procedural
idea in democratic theory that people whose interests are affected by a decision
presumptively should have some say in making that decision.
If you think about the Boston tea party,
which the current tea partiers are trying to piggyback piggyback on the
legitimacy of it was the same notion.
No,
right?
No.
What without representation?
What?
Yes.
Okay.
So it's the same idea that,
that people who are affected by decisions,
if you're going to attack SAS,
we want to be involved in,
we want to have representation in the decisions about taxation.
And so,
uh,
it's,
it's trying to capture that idea,
uh,
that I'm talking about when I talk about democratic justice and I want to
describe first a general argument and then some particulars.
The first is that this rests on a broad conception of politics.
Okay?
Uh,
what do I mean by a broad conception of politics?
Well,
consider this fact when we talk about,
uh,
those of you who have read political philosophy in the history of the tradition
will know,
uh,
that for most of the great theorists of the past,
um,
the organization of the political system was only one piece of a theory of
politics.
Plato,
Aristotle,
Locke Male,
uh,
all of these thinkers thought that it was important to have a theory of family
life,
a theory of education,
a theory of how the whole society operated.
Um,
politics is not just about what goes on in buildings in Washington and in
Hartford.
Uh,
it was a broad conception of politics.
Um,
and one of the criticisms of much contemporary political theory has been that it
ignores
the broad,
the broad society.
So for example,
it was a,
it was a criticism made of roles as theory of justice by feminists that it
ignored the structure of the family.
Um,
roles talked about heads of households as the basic,
um,
uh,
representative individuals behind the veil of ignorance.
And when he was saying that this was part of the basic,
the,
his theory was a theory of the basic structure of society.
Feminists,
theorists,
hutches,
Susan Okin,
a now deceased and others made the argument,
how can you say you're talking about the basic structure of society while
ignoring the family and a roles eventually conceded the validity,
the validity of that criticism.
And s came to say toward the end of his life that had he to do it over,
he would have,
he would have included the family as part of the basic structure of society.
So if politics is about power relations,
then presumably you should think about power relations wherever they occur in
social life and not simply power relations as they occur in the political system
narrowly defined.
And so the spirit of my argument for a democratic justice is to base to base it
on a broad conception of politics rather than a narrow one.
Of course,
that doesn't mean that every political relationship is politicized relationship.
We might say that the family is an intensely political institution and indeed,
uh,
debates about education and debates about abortion and the bay debates about
many other subjects have politicized the family in recent times.
But in the 1950s,
it was not a politicized institution.
It was seen as something beyond politics,
um,
of no of no relevance to politic.
So what institutions are politicized in that sense,
subconscious us consciously conceived of as political is a separate question
from what institutions are in fact,
political.
If we define political as involved in the,
um,
okay,
in the reproduction of power,
relationships in the society.
So we have a broad conception of politics.
And then secondly,
we have a semi contextual argument.
And this is,
this is to try and take account of what people like Mcintyre have argued that,
um,
what people are willing to accept is largely conditioned by the,
the social circumstances into which they are born,
the traditions that they find structuring their lives,
that uh,
we have to take into account the context in which people find themselves,
but there's more to life than just the context that is to say,
um,
there are inherited traditions and practices,
but as we reproduce them into the future,
we have choices to make and we need principles to guide those choices.
And so,
um,
the argument of democratic justice is that we do develop general principles of a
sort,
but that semi contextual that is,
they play themselves out differently in different historical circumstances and
in different parts of the world.
Uh,
so you may for example,
have an affirmation of the idea of um,
okay,
non domination in family life,
but that's going to have to be worked out very differently in,
in America in 2010 then it might've been in America in 1950.
Not to mention in countries that have inherited polygamous systems of
traditional marriage,
we're going to have to think in context sensitive ways about how to realize
those general principles in the different circumstances.
Yeah.
A third point,
and I apologize here,
I did,
uh,
swear off a impenetrable jargon at the beginning of this course and you might
think,
uh,
talking about super ordinate and subordinate goods is,
is the use of,
uh,
not very user friendly terminology.
But let me explain what I mean by this.
If we take a broad conception of politics,
one of the things that follows from it is that power relations are everywhere.
Power infuses everything we do.
Okay.
There's PR,
there are power relations in the family,
there are power relations in the workplace.
There are power relations in sports teams.
There are power relations in classrooms.
Power infuses everything.
This is of course an idea for which the French political commentator now
deceased by the name of Fuko is famous for pointing out that power is
everywhere.
But of course it's as old as the hills.
Plato was of have the same view that power relations are everywhere.
And indeed,
the reason Plato affirmed a broad conception of politics was too,
he was because he recognized that power is exercised everywhere in the society.
And so,
uh,
if you,
the theory of politics is really a theory of power relations,
it's going to have to track a pout wherever it goes.
So if power relations are ubiquitous and politics as ubiquitous,
then it seems like while everything is politics,
and it's that last phrase that I want to dissent from that last phrase in Fuko
or in Plato that I want to descend from,
because in fact,
what we really see is not that everything is power,
but that power infuses everything and there's an important difference.
Yes,
there are power relations in the classroom.
Teaching fellow has certain kind of power over you.
I have a certain kind of power over you.
Um,
but that's not the only thing that goes on in the classroom.
Presumably also what goes on in the classroom is enlightenment.
Uh,
not in the Big East sense of that enlightenment,
but enlightenment in the sense of communicating knowledge to you in the firm.
Yes,
there are power relations in the firm.
Managers have power over workers.
Um,
shareholders have power of a manager's,
at least in certain circumstances.
Of course there are power relations in firms,
but the exercise of power is not the only thing that goes on in firms.
Uh,
there's the production of goods and services that goes on in,
in firms,
right?
Yes,
there are power relations in sports teams manage.
Again,
coaches have power over.
Players don't,
as you might say,
have power over coaches,
even university presidents.
Um,
sometimes,
so of course there are power relations associated with sports teams,
but again,
sports teams are not just about power relations.
There are also about playing sports.
Well,
so you can,
as you can,
you can get the point from these examples.
We could go,
uh,
everywhere,
through society and see,
yes,
uh,
social relations,
often involve power,
but that's not all they involve.
So to my way of thinking,
the superordinate good is the playing excellent sport or communicate or
producing goods and services or communicating,
uh,
enlightenment to students.
Those are,
there were super ordinate goods or what macintyre called the internal goods.
Um,
when he was talking about his practices.
Those are the superordinate goods that guide,
uh,
our activities in different walks of life.
Um,
the subordinate goods have to do with the power relations.
And what I want to say is that the goal of a democratic conception of justice
should be to democratize the subordinate relations as much as possible while
interfering with the super ordinate goods as little as possible.
You at you at the end of the day want that sports team to be able to play the
best football it can play or you want the students to learn as much as they can
possibly learn well,
you want the firm to produce efficiently,
as efficiently as possible,
the goods and services that it produces,
right?
So that those are the super on the ordinate goods.
However,
there are,
there is this fact about power being mixed up in the,
in the pursuit of superordinate goods and democratic justice is about
democratizing the power dimensions of human interaction while interfering with
the non power dimensions as little as possible.
And the creative challenge is to find ways to do that.
And I think that when we're thinking about conditioning the subordinate
dimensions democratically,
they're really two dimensions of democratic justice that have both present in
that famous quote from Nelson Mandela that I read to you a few moments ago,
what is the idea of collective self government?
It's the idea that as the principle of affected interests intimate,
anyone who is affected by a decision should have a presumptive say in the making
of that decision doesn't necessarily mean everybody has an equal say.
We'll get to those issues later.
But everybody is presumed to have a say in the making of decisions that affect
them.
No taxation without representation.
It's the idea of collective self,
government.
If we're going to be affected by decisions,
we should have a say in making them.
Yeah.
But then separate from that and independent of it,
it's the idea of the legitimacy of opposition,
the legitimacy of resisting decisions that you don't like.
And I think there are two reasons for this.
Forget about the presumption against hierarchy for a minute.
I'll get to that shortly.
Just focus on the idea of institutionalizing opposition.
There are two reasons for that.
One I've already alluded to today,
which is that we're always fumbling in the dark.
We're always resisting things that haven't worked well in the past.
We're trying to change things.
We might be rebuilding the ship at sea as um,
as uh,
Devlin says,
but we are trying to rebuild the ship.
We are trying to make things better as we reproduce them into the future.
Um,
and unless we have the freedom to oppose the existing order,
then uh,
the possibility of change becomes elusive.
But a second and more fundamental reason that we should institutionalize rights
of opposition is that you now know from taking this course that there are no
perfect decision rules.
We saw that if we look,
if we just focus on the arm's length types of transactions that characterize um,
national level politics,
politics in buildings in Washington,
we did end up with a presumption in favor of majority rule when we,
when we worked our way through,
um,
the,
the difficulties with Buchanan and telic and Brian Barry and,
and ray and all of that,
um,
that,
that other things being equal,
you protect yourself best with majority rule,
but it's not a perfect decision rule,
you know,
from condo say and Kenneth Arrow that there is no perfect way to aggregate
preferences into a social welfare function.
So if there's no perfect decision rule,
one of the things that follows from that is that whatever the decision rule,
whatever the result,
there are going to be people who object to it and who object to it legitimately
people who are going to feel that their interests have not been taken adequate
[inaudible] into account.
And so opposition is important for that reason to give people the possibility of
trying to get things changed.
Very important for the stability of democracy as well.
Because if you don't create avenues for loyal opposition over time,
you're more likely to get this loyal opposition.
If people feel there's no possibility of change,
they might as well reach for their guns.
So,
um,
there are two dimensions of d of democratic justice for that reason.
There's collective self,
government and then this idea of institutionalizing opposition in practice.
I suggest that one of the most important ways in which we institutionalize
opposition is with a presumption against hierarchy.
If you think of the examples I just gave you,
sports teams,
classes,
um,
firms,
you could think of many others,
armies,
um,
uh,
families,
they're all hierarchical to a very considerable extent.
All those social forms are hierarchical and um,
often the hierarchy is,
is essential to the realization of the superordinate.
Good in question.
So it's not the case that hierarchies unnecessarily bad,
but it's when hierarchies atrophy into systems of domination that they become
bad power corrupts.
And the,
the problem is to prevent those who are higher up in hierarchies from,
um,
taking advantage of their hierarchical hierarchical authority in order to
dominate others.
And so when we confront hierarchical social arrangements,
there were a lot,
there are a number of questions that we can ask.
What I'm calling here,
we can interrogate hierarchies.
We can ask is a hierarchy inevitable?
Well,
the hierarchy of a parent over a child is inevitable,
but the hierarchy in say in the 1950s of a hundred husband over a wife was not
inevitable.
If the hierarchy is inevitable,
we're going to have to think about it in one way.
If it's not inevitable,
we're going to think about it in a different way.
Is the higher the degree of hierarchy appropriate children must be subordinated
to their parents,
but maybe they don't have to be subordinated for 18 years.
We have the arguments of the children's rights movement that wanted to treat
children as,
as miniature adults,
almost from infant hood.
So we,
we have to think about is the hierarchy appropriate?
Whose interest as the hierarchy serve?
Is it really in the interests of the production of this super superordinate
good.
Think of a boss who has hierarchical authority of our secretary and says to the
secretary at some point,
uh,
unless you are willing to go to bed with me,
you're gone.
You're not going to get a promotion.
Yeah.
Then the hierarchical authority has atrophied into a system of domination
because the,
the efficiencies that would be gained from the boss having authority over his
secretary of being perverted into,
uh,
something that operates in the interest of the boss perhaps.
Um,
but not,
uh,
it,
it doesn't serve the hierarchy as it was created.
How fluid is a hierarchy is itself liquidating.
If,
if you think of the situation where a child becomes a parent,
my child becomes an adult,
that's a self liquidating hierarchy.
Whereas if we go back to the 19th century and the father turned his daughter
over to her husband,
uh,
that would be a non south liquidating hierarchy.
Is there vertical mobility within the hierarchy?
Think of the debates in the Catholic Church about whether a woman can become a
priest.
Um,
there does seem there's not a lot of vertical mobility within that hierarchy.
Is the hierarchy symmetrical?
We think of the defense of polygamy,
but most societies that have polygamy allow a man to have many,
a husband to have many wives but not a wife,
to have many husband
asymmetrical hierarchies are more suspect than symmetrical ones.
What are the opportunities for exit?
Can people leave hierarchical social situations?
You think about polygamy in uh,
South Africa.
It's essentially elective.
People can choose polygamous arrangements but they don't have to.
Whereas in some societies and fundamentalist cultures,
polygamous marriage is enshrined in the legal system.
Other things being equal.
Um,
hierarchical systems are more suspect when the costs of exit or high for the
people at the bottom.
How Angela is the hierarchy.
For instance,
we look at the Amish.
It's a withdrawing sect.
Uh,
they don't want to restructure the rest of the social order.
So that is presumptively less suspect than a fundamentalist group that does want
to restructure the social order.
So there,
there are all of these questions.
One can ask about hierarchical social relationships.
You have to ask them in a context sensitive fashion,
and then you can get some answers that tell you what we should be trying to
pursue in the name of democratic justice.
And I will pick up with some of those answers on Wednesday.